so
oh wait i don't know i did part two we
gotta do part one first
so this is a woman who thought it'd be a
good idea
to sleep with her daughter's baby daddy
now i don't
i don't know what world these women live
in where like you're competing with your
mom for guys
i never had this
we're just gonna watch the video wasting
time
let's get it this is what you do with my
mom are you serious
i know you're lying and you just sitting
there quiet you ain't got to say mom
really you ain't got to say really so
you just no i don't want to hear that
yeah i'ma put it on facebook i want
everybody to see the two
right here what they doing in my bed my
bad i'm still your mother i don't care
who you are obviously you don't care
that i'm your daughter right you over
here sleeping with my baby daddy that's
my baby daddy you don't clean because
i've been
too get your butt out i'll get
what no the camera's all in your face
take my off because i paid for it
give me this shirt i bought that no give
me my
listen i don't know what's worse about
this situation i ain't going nowhere
like the audacity what are you
that is so cringe to watch literally
i can't hold my expressions in like it's
so bad
imagine imagine your mother in bed with
your boyfriend or baby daddy whoever
right and she's giving you advice while
she's laying up right next to him and
he's just lounging did you not see him
he was so comfortable he was way too
comfortable with that and then she goes
on to say that they weren't doing
anything
that did not look like it was not
anything
like
come on
i can't even imagine looking at my mom
and then she's giving every like she's
giving her relationship advice that's
the audacity right there
go ahead allie what are your thoughts
my thoughts is uh
like it's possible this was a skit
supposedly it could have been however
nonetheless these things do happen in
the hood and it's like some really
really ghetto stuff like i wouldn't i'm
never going back to the hood i've
disavowed it it's stupid like women are
out here really doing this stuff i think
i think growing up i heard a story one
time where a lady left her man for her
stepson and i was like y'all like this
is this is the plot of
a prawn video like what
so yeah the audacity of these ghetto a
mugs i'm done
oh my god the first
go ahead sorry go ahead i just want to
say the fact that this would be a skit
in the first place is just like um i did
a reaction of the lady who basically was
pissed off that her boyfriend or husband
bought her a brand new audi
and
like everyone was saying that that was
also a skit why
why are these things skits why are
people recording this like
this is what i don't understand if it is
fake
why
for attention that person looks like it
like they all look like idiots there
right
and it just i don't know it makes no
sense why would you make a skip like
skit like that to get attention like
you could do anything else with your
life
anything else
and you know what i don't you know
what's crazy to me i can't imagine like
a world that i would live in where my
mom is posting ass pictures on instagram
or trying to sleep with guys that i'm
trying to sleep with you know or like
competing with me like this is why women
can't be by themselves
okay like this is why we're supposed to
get married
because
we just be trifling you know what i mean
like this is why
this is why i'm trying to find a man
because i don't want to do that
i can't be like bad at 50. no no no it's
true it's true i make the worst
decisions by myself but for me mostly
it's like i'm too nice i'm like this
person isn't going to rob me here's 500
my husband's like are you stupid or are
you dumb like which one is it i'm like
you know what snacks facts i don't even
know why i asked like
[Laughter]
guys it's bad it's a weird world out
there like really weird world that we're
living in and and the worst part about
it is that like before maybe in like you
know like 20 years ago
before the internet was a thing before
tick tock and before like these things
happened right but it wasn't all up in
our face like we have to
literally deal with all of this crap in
our face constantly
and i think that's the worst part is you
know
just confronting
the craziness every single day i wake up
and my phone is like blaring people like
people screaming out of my phone and i'm
like this is the world that we live in
just pure insanity and that's what gets
propelled
in the forefront of social media and the
regular media they want everyone to be
crazy
well i mean that's how i felt when roe v
wade happened and i kept saying a bunch
of people's thoughts online so i went to
my local college campus because i was
like are people really bugging but when
i went to campus i went on
this app called yik yak it's like
anonymous thing and where you can post
your thoughts and it's like whisper
and you know there were some crazy women
up in there talking about like
i have to get an iud they're going to
outlaw birth control like
just turn off the handmaid's tale but i
also think social media really shows us
how people feel because i used to be in
college and i would be like you know no
like i kind of think leftists hate me
like i kind of think they hate me and
all my professors would tell me oh like
you know it's it's magnified i'm like i
don't know because i'm friends with my
friends in real life on facebook they
say they hate people that voted for
donny so like you sure sure these people
like me like i don't i don't think so so
i think social media magnifies things
true but i also think it like allows
people to share their
i don't know crappy beliefs just like
the worst things that you could think
they're like oh let me type this out
there let me add my my scum to society
yeah um i think pearl you were talking
about this how
if you are an influencer
influencer or like a creator you almost
feel like it's even magnified more
because you're constantly
in this state of
like fight or flight like you're
constantly fighting you're constantly in
disagreement because that's what drives
numbers that's what drives attention
like people don't care that we're
talking about um how to be a better
woman how to be more feminine how to
create healthy happy marriages they want
to see us like [ __ ] talk other people on
the internet like that's really and it's
not i mean like we're doing it like i
will give it to the people but like
but that's what they want to see they
want to see drama they want to see all
of this the the filth come up
from the internet and that's why these
videos take off and then get you know
thrown up on every other social media
platform because
it's like
let's amplify the delusion let's amplify
the
the confusion everything like
the the
crappiest part of society let's put it
on the forefront and make it make
everyone think that this is normal
like normalized dysfunction